Hi, I'm Roger Ross Williams.
I'm an African-American
man with dreadlocks
all kind of bunched up in a
little band on top of my head.
I am in Brooklyn, New
York in my office.
And behind me is a
bookshelf with some sort
of obnoxious awards.
And it's great to be here.
Hi, I'm Jim LeBrecht I'm
a 64-year-old white man.
I've got longish curly
hair, graying goatee,
and I've got glasses on.
I'm sitting in my home office,
which is in the back behind me
is a red wall with some
music and movie posters.
Hi, I'm Bao Nguyen.
I'm a 36-year-old
Asian-American man
with black hair
and a black beard.
I'm wearing a black polo.
I'm in my studio in Los Angeles.
And behind me are a large bay of
windows, a sofa, and some books
and posters.
Hi, I'm Dawn Porter.
I am a medium
brown-skinned woman
of a certain age in my prime.
I am upstairs in my home office
with a very cute modern chair
next to me with a red cushion.
I have on a kind of
pink plaid shirt.
And my hair is short
and curly natural.
Hi, my name is Lisa Cortés.
I am an Afro-Latina.
My skin is cocoa brown,
kissed by the sun.
I have dreadlocks.
I am wearing white
glasses, a black dress,
with a blue and green
and gold necklace.
The walls behind me are red.
And I am speaking from
Sugar Hill in Harlem.
Welcome to the next episode
of Academy Dialogues--
It Starts with
Us, our continuing
series of conversations about
race, ethnicity, gender,
history, opportunity,
and the art of filmmaking
hosted by the Academy.
My name is [? Shawn ?]
[? Finney, ?] and our topic
today is documentaries
through our lens.
We're honored to have five
highly awarded documentary
filmmakers join us for this
discussion about the challenges
people from
underrepresented communities
still face in the
documentary world.
Our moderator is the prolific
filmmaker and Academy governor,
Roger Ross Williams.
Roger is an award-winning
director, producer, writer,
and became the first
African-American director
to win an Academy Award with his
short film Music by Prudence.
Joining Roger will be
director producer Lisa Cortés,
filmmaker Jim LeBrecht, director
and producer Bao Nguyen,
and filmmaker Dawn Porter.
We look forward to
your conversation.
Welcome, everybody.
Thank you for coming
today and participating
in this in the dialogues.
I wanted to start--
so the conversation about
who gets to tell the story
is not a new one.
We all know that.
We've traditionally been defined
through other people's lenses.
The documentary industry
has been seen as a whole
as progressive, as someone as
a community that is actually
ahead of the game in the
entertainment business.
But I think the
dirty little secret
is the documentary community
is not that ahead of the game
and that we have a
lot of work to do.
I wanted to start by sort
of taking your temperature
about kind of the state
of documentary for people
from underrepresented
communities
and where you think
we are right now.
And I want to--
and since you all
are coming from
different perspectives,
and I'm going to start with
the elder statesman here, Dawn
Porter.
Well, it's a joy, a privilege
to be here with all of you
whose work I respect so
much, and I appreciate you
all being here.
And of course, the
greatest admiration,
love, and respect, and
honor to my governor.
So I think that we are at a
very strange time, coming off
of the idea and
the common wisdom
that this is the golden
age of documentary.
And there's more work than
ever, and there's more appetite
and audience appetite.
And there's particularly
an appetite for stories
about underrepresented people.
I think that's a
testament just to how
broad and vast
the audience likes
to see themselves on screen.
And yet, when I think
about who the creators are.
They are being asked
to tell those stories.
I do not see that demand
meeting this supply.
And I mean that
by I have the kind
of feeling that while there is
demand for stories about people
from underrepresented
communities,
I don't see the gatekeepers
or people with the funds
to make those stories happening.
I don't see a really
wide net being cast.
And I think that
that's a big problem.
And one thing--
I think this conversation is
necessary, but it's also hard.
And it's hard because
the documentary-- there
is a community here.
And we do work together,
or we appear in panels,
or we support each other.
We help each other.
And so I think people have been
a little reticent to criticize
when filmmakers take on
projects that maybe there's
another voice that's better
suited to take on that project
so I welcome this conversation.
I'm going to be honest
about my feelings about it.
But I think we need to push
the people who can really
greenlight and make films
happen to look beyond the very
narrow group of
filmmakers that they
are looking to
tell these stories
if there's a demand for.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Bao, you're new,
relatively young filmmaker.
And I just want to talk to
you about your perspective
as someone who is--
I guess Be Water is
your first film--
someone sort of starting out
in the doc industry and what
your observations are.
Well, I just wanted to
also express my gratitude
for being invited to
this really amazing panel
of fellow filmmakers.
I really respect as well.
Be Water is actually
my second film,
but my first film
was not in the way
that I really wanted
to tell that story.
And I think a lot of
times as filmmakers
we feel like it's necessarily to
tell it to a certain audience.
We're often asked like oh,
how does this story relate
to a Western audience,
to an American audience,
to a white audience?
And some of that
really kind of I think
filters our own voice in a
way that feels inauthentic,
and it's not honest.
And what I found with
making Be Water which
I was so fortunate
and privileged to make
was that I could tell a story
that was unapologetically
Asian-American, that
was unapologetically
about Bruce Lee's struggle as
an Asian-American in Hollywood.
And I think that
is shifting a bit.
But I recognize that it sort of
becomes a trend in the industry
that we can have
these periods of OK,
we're going to have films
that are very authentic,
and then we're going to pat
ourselves on the back about it.
But is it something that's
sustainable over time?
And I think learning
from Bruce Lee, actually,
I understood what it meant to
be authentic as a filmmaker,
as a storyteller.
I've used those
lessons to sort of try
to push myself for
as a filmmaker,
as a documentary filmmaker,
and not think so much of oh,
how does this connect
to the Western audience?
How does this connect to
a white American audience?
It's like I should think of
myself as an audience member
that matters as well, right?
And I think we are
often told, in terms
of these spaces for
documentary filmmakers--
especially in development.
It's really hard to get films
developed, because we are--
I think many BIPOC,
marginalized filmmakers,
they're not seen
for their potential.
We have to live up to a
higher threshold of success
than a lot of other
filmmakers out there who
personally have the
same experience in terms
of work experience.
But I think we
have to also think
about the value
of our experience
as marginalized communities,
as marginalized individuals,
and not think about the
price of representation
but the value of
representation more.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Lisa, you came from
the scripted world--
produced Precious.
And your second documentary
All In: The Fight for Democracy
is dropping today or tomorrow.
Do you see a difference
in the doc community
from the scripted community?
And what is that?
Well, I'm not different in it
in how I operate in either.
I love what Bao said about being
unapologetic in your voice,
in your vision.
And oftentimes, what
we're trying to figure out
is how did we arrive at this
moment and with this story.
And for myself, I am
looking to center the value
of my experience, and what
it brings to the project,
And my responsibility
to my community.
So whether it's
scripted or narrative,
I kind of-- my north star
as a creator doesn't change.
Jim, I feel like often
differently abled people
are left--
especially definitely
filmmakers are left--
out of the conversation.
I've been on many
diversity panels.
And when we were
talking about diversity,
we often leave out
people with disabilities.
I made a film about a young
woman with a disability.
And my eyes were open to my
own sort of bias, my own--
being uncomfortable.
And it was a huge
learning curve to learn,
to exist in that
community and understand
who they are as they were
all young people in Africa.
I want to ask you to talk a
little bit about that and about
in the documentary community,
about what voices like yours,
and why we're not hearing
from a lot of people
with disabilities.
Well, thank you
for that question.
And I also want to echo
how absolutely honored I am
to be with all of you today and
to be part of this discussion.
And to be honest with
you, I think that just
my presence here today is
kind of what the issue is that
just getting in the door,
simply being in the room
has been difficult for a lot
of people with disabilities.
And indeed, I was seeing--
just a few years
ago, I was seeing
all these different diversity
and inclusion movements,
including at the IDA, the
International Documentary
Association.
And when they had
Getting Real in 2016,
the convention was all about
kind of inclusion stuff,
and there wasn't anything
about disability.
But I've seen a lot of
really positive change.
And the IDA really embraced
that and really addressed that.
And when they had Getting
Real two years ago,
we had panels on
disabled filmmakers.
And we had a convening of
disabled filmmakers and allies.
And that was the first
time that people actually--
different filmmakers, all sorts
of different disabilities,
or if they were dead
or hard of hearing,
were in the same
room with each other.
So I think that
people are finally
starting to recognize that we
are a marginalized community,
and that what we
are dealing with
is a civil rights
issue in our community.
That it's not purely like
medical, these people are sick,
but that really this is
about being part of society.
So I'm more optimistic though
than I was a couple years ago.
Great.
You used-- you talked
about "diversity"
and "inclusiveness"--
those words.
And I want to talk a little
bit about those terms.
And how many how
many panels have we
seen about diversity, about
throwing around these terms.
There's every now with this sort
of racial reckoning happening
in America.
Every corporation, the
entertainment industry,
everyone is jumping on
this sort of diversity,
using the word "diversity,"
and jumping on this bandwagon.
For me it feels like that
diversity means assimilation.
It means we have to fit within--
they want a person of color,
a person with a disability.
They want them in
the room but just
to reinforce their own ideology,
their own way that they've
always done things--
not really opening the door
to our voices and our stories.
So I would just
want to go around.
And I wanted to ask
each one of you, how
do you define "diversity,"
"inclusion," these terms?
How do you define "diversity"?
And what does it mean to you?
And I'll start with
you, Dawn Porter.
I think there's-- in
the black community,
we always say like we don't
usually have the opportunity
to hide our difference, because
I wear my difference proudly
and happily.
But I think that there are--
I'm very concerned about
people who are not wealthy,
people from other areas who
are not from New York City
or from Los Angeles
or San Francisco,
people from the
middle of the country.
I feel like there is a--
the reason that we
want authentic voices
is because we want to do
something approximating truth.
And so I really love flat
out saying about whatever
our differences are.
And that begs the question
is, what are we comparing to?
But whatever our
individual experiences are,
that is a gift.
That is what we
want to encourage.
So I do really try and think
hard about economic diversity,
geographic diversity,
and life experience.
No matter what race you are,
if you come from a really
kind of difficult
financial circumstance,
I think you do have a different
perspective on issues.
And I think that
those are voices that
really should be encouraged.
Yeah.
Jim?
I often think about this
as who is not in the room
if I'm really looking
about inclusion.
And indeed, what Dawn has talked
about here is really important.
I never thought about people
who were simply geographically
marginalized and
their ability to be
able to tell their stories.
And even within the
disabled community,
there's such a wide umbrella.
There are people with
cognitive issues.
mental health issues
that they're dealing with.
And that it's important
for us to make sure
that we are really
not leaving anybody
behind in regards to how we
are looking out for each other.
And I think that
for me, personally,
that obviously goes well
beyond just disability.
But that my experience
performs how
I look at anybody
that I'm working with
and when I check and see
who's not in the room.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean it's like
what Angela Davis said.
Diversity is a
corporate strategy,
and I feel like it's becoming
more and more that way
in many conversations.
And I mean, I appreciate
that this conversation is--
the word "diversity" is part
of the panel title, right?
And
I think it's all
about like how we
center anything in the world.
What's the standard?
What's considered normal?
And when we diverged
from that, that's what
diversity is considered, right?
Who determines
what the center is,
what the center of
our narratives are,
what the center--
what the gold standard is?
What's the center of merit?
What's the center of success?
And even thinking
geographically,
Western cinema, Western
films is considered
the gold standard of success.
But I think even this
past year with Parasite
winning, I thought
it's very encouraging,
because we're recentering what
the best picture is in a way.
And when you think of
that, it just opens up
the opportunities.
It opens up our borders of not
just thinking about the West
as being the center
of the world.
And I think given how global
or how globally we're connected
and trying to build
community, especially
through film, documentaries
in a way I think
have been a bit more
progressive in that.
If you look at the best
documentary nominations
last year, Honeyland,
For Sarma, I
think those opportunities
to rethink the center.
And how we're
centering narratives
is important when we're
thinking about diversity.
Because to me, a
white male is diverse.
Someone brought that up in
an earlier Academy Dialogue.
And I was like, that's perfect.
For me, I'm not diverse.
I am exists as who I am.
And Dawn was saying when
you're around your community,
you don't feel diverse.
You just feel like you're there.
You're allowed to be there.
You're allowed to exist.
So I think rethinking--
as we're reckoning a lot of
things in America in the world,
we have to also think of
what it means to be diverse.
Exactly.
I love that.
Most of the world--
when I was driving here, I
was thinking most of the world
is not white, European-centered
reality perspective.
And so what is this--
what does diversity mean?
It means that we're trying
to fit within that--
we're trying to-- the
types of films we make,
everything we do, we're trying
to-- are we trying to like fit
within that sort
of [? their ?] sort
of [? reality we're ?]
trying to assimilate.
But to be an--
to be an anti-racist, it's
not about assimilating
into anyone's reality.
It's about your own
communities like Dawn said.
It's about who you are
in your own community.
So I think that's
really important part
of the conversation here.
Lisa, Lisa Cortés.
Well, Roger, I think so many--
we've talked a lot about
diversity, inclusion,
but then measuring
it against progress.
Like who is getting
awarded the projects?
Who has the access
to the funding?
And I've been
dreaming of a world
where we can stop having
the conversations,
because we will see that
tangible progress has
been made in terms of
who's getting projects.
And more importantly,
that otherness
is not being used as
a way of diminishing
the value of what we were create
and the visibility of what
we create.
In this conversation, we
have to look at privilege.
Because that is certainly
one of the boundaries
that also comes in
to this conversation.
Whatever privilege decision
makers are is working from is--
we have all seen.
It has been a deterrent
that those gatekeepers
have introduced.
So this is an interesting time.
It's a time of reckoning.
And I think if we all want
to get to truth in our work,
in this business, and
in our storytelling,
we have to have these very
difficult conversations
and move beyond the
conversation to action.
There was something
that you said about--
as governor and as
someone who heads up
the documentary
diversity committee,
I've actually had
filmmakers complain to me
that good old sort
of American films
are not being nominated,
that too many foreign films--
that would sound familiar too
many foreign films are getting
nominated in the
documentary category,
that there were two films
from Syria last year.
And it just blows my mind that
the privilege, and that you
are entitled because you are an
American, which means you are--
sort of is a code word
for white filmmakers
who have dominated
the doc branch.
So that has been a big
sort of pet peeve of mine,
so I just had to say that.
How much-- you guys
are-- all of you--
are all really successful.
You all have major, major films
that are with big distributors.
And your names are known.
You're out there in the world.
How much responsibility
do you guys
feel to lift up
others like yourself?
So is the weight-- there's
so much weight on all of you
guys, because you're at the top.
So Jim talk to me about that.
Do you feel that sense
of responsibility?
I think it's--
I think it's really huge.
I think that my responsibility,
I feel, is to share the mic,
is to bring other people,
provide opportunities
for other people
within my community
and outside my
community that I know
that have not been represented.
And so it's and
also there are not
that many well-known
filmmakers with disabilities.
So I feel like boy, I
better not screw up.
But well beyond
that, it's just--
I'm looking forward to
the day where many of us
are known for our work.
And so that it's--
so I'm not being
terribly clear here,
but I think my point is
that when we are leaders,
it's really responsive.
It's important that we take
this very, very seriously
and try to help others.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Lisa, you said that--
you were quoted
as saying we don't
need an inclusivity writer.
I believe that was your quote.
Elaborate on that.
Well, I'd first like to jump in
and talk about your question,
Roger, about responsibility.
What my parents always
impressed upon me
is that responsibility
comes with accountability
to your community.
One of my favorite speeches is
from Dr. Martin Luther King,
and it's called the
"Drum Major Instinct."
And he says that
you can be a star.
You can be all these
wonderful things.
But if you cannot be of
service, then that is what is
your greatest responsibility.
That's my responsibility.
And I love it because he's like,
it doesn't matter if you can't
do all these wonderful things.
You can always be a
drum major for justice.
You can be a drum
major for peace.
You can be a drum major
for accountability.
And if people don't
know the speech,
I'm not doing it
service, because it's
so beautiful and eloquent.
But it is something that is
one of my important guiding
principles.
Now, when I made a
comment about like
we shouldn't need to
have inclusively writers.
We shouldn't need to.
But because it
shouldn't be the dictum
to have cast and crew that
is reflective of the world
that we live in.
A world that is not
centered in whiteness.
centered in one gender.
And it shouldn't
be the exception
that oh, wow, we've done this.
It should be the norm
that the all the beautiful
faces I'm seeing in
this conversation,
that I get to see
representatives
of our communities
working on our projects.
So for clarity, it's like we
shouldn't have to have it.
But until things
change, we should.
Because obviously the people
who are making decisions
and green lighting projects
are seeing things through,
historically, a
very narrow prism.
I mean in 1963, the NAACP
went to Hollywood and said,
would you at least please hire
one Negro on your production?
So yes, we have made progress.
But there is tremendous more
progress that needs to be made.
And if it needs to happen via
a writer to give awareness
to the incredible
talent that is out there
but hasn't had the opportunity,
well then, so be it.
Hear, hear.
Yeah.
Listening to Jim, I think
part of what you're describing
is what--
Roger and Lisa will be familiar
with this-- the black tax.
You want to be better, because
you don't want to mess it up
for everybody else
And I see nods, and I
see people feeling that.
And I think what is important
to recognize about that is most
of us willingly take that on.
I want people who
look like all of us
to keep-- because I know how
hard it is to do what we do.
I want to mentor everybody.
I want to answer
every phone call.
I want to do all those things.
But it is taxing.
And when our skill is
creativity and focus,
it really becomes a lot.
You find yourself spread too
thin out of a desire to help.
And so I do think
as much as we know--
I know Lisa helps everybody.
Like Lisa is
constantly answering
phone calls,
answering questions.
I know all--
I don't know about that.
But I'm thinking that
all of us do that.
And I think that
there's something
we should be thinking
about in doing that.
Like if we're spending
25% of our time doing
that, it's 25% it's less
time doing good work.
And it does take a toll.
So let's be honest
here, you can't really
be as selective in your help
as you would like to be,
because you're trying so
desperately to give help
where it is needed.
And you're so needed
in such a wide variety.
So that that's one thing
I'm just thinking about.
I'm wondering how you all deal
with it and what you think.
The other thing is I am very
excited about the Academy's
best picture requirements.
It's not until 2024, and
we will see what happens.
But I think we have
an opportunity now.
We have these next few years to
make that not a "check the box"
situation but to make it
a real, substantive, kind
of field building.
Because that's
what I want to see.
I want to see the field
seeded and built so that--
there's so many people
of color and people
with disabilities and people
from geographic backgrounds
that you're just picking the
right person for the project
instead of--
and I think we all want
to be known for our work.
I don't want to be picked
because I'm a Black woman, as
proud as I am of that.
I want to be picked
because I'm suited
to the material for
any number of reasons--
for my style, for my whatever.
So I guess I just throw
that out to all of us.
Well, Dawn, let's talk
a little bit about that.
Because--
Can I-- sorry-- touch upon this
question before we move on?
It will continue on to
what Dawn was saying.
I think what-- when we asked
a question, who's the best
person to tell the story?
And we do-- these projects
get picked in terms of someone
from that community.
Immediately, a
lot of people just
want to discredit and
discount that experience
as being valuable
and as some sort
of-- as a skill set to bring
to that project in many ways.
And what Jim was saying, there
was a great burden for me
to tell the story of Be Water,
because it was Bruce Lee.
And as an Asian-American
male having the privilege
to tell the story of Bruce
Lee, I saw it as a privilege.
Because we don't
have so many heroes,
so many stories, so
many myths that we
can take for granted
like other people do.
We have to, sadly, succeed
and knock it out of the park
a lot of the time.
Because we don't have these
opportunities so much.
And I think what Dawn
was saying too about
like having the responsibility
to kind of pay it forward,
but not always having the
time for ourselves to do that.
And I think in many
ways, us doing our work,
being authentic, is a
way to pay it forward.
Because we are we're
helping build lanes,
helping build space for
the future for people
to see that oh, if--
Bao was able to make a film
about an Asian-American
and make it be about
his Asian-Americaness.
That just creates more ideas.
And we're working in a space of
imagination sometimes in film.
We want to build more
spaces for imagination
and for us, documentary
filmmakers, imagined realities.
And I think when we're talking
to other filmmakers who
might be white male that
have more experience,
they're not judged
in the same way.
Because they don't have that
same type of background.
And again, we don't
value representation.
And we don't value experience
and lived experience,
and how that
contributes to a project
like how our pains our
struggles relate to that story.
And I think that's so important.
And when we think about
quote unquote "diversity"
and "representation,"
I feel like I
can tell Bruce Lee's story
in an Asian-American way,
because I've been harassed.
I've been discriminated
as an Asian-American.
And although other
filmmakers who
are not part of my
community can understand it,
can they feel it?
And I think that's important.
Dawn, we know that in the
industry, whenever there's
a Black project
with Black content,
there is a list of five--
you, me, a few other people.
--I feel like I should
just call you, and be like,
do you want to do this?
But I just want to talk about
that, because it's so crazy.
Why did they go to
the same five people?
Do they think we don't know?
Like guess what?
Yes, there is a [? Black ?]
[? back ?] phone.
And we pick it up
after you call.
We're like, did they call you?
What do you think?
Oh, are you busy?
OK, who should we give this to?
I mean-- yes.
What was your question?
I just-- how do we
open up the field?
How do we-- what do
we do to change that?
I desperately need to change.
I mean, I've had this
conversation with so many
people and trying to say, hey--
I feel like-- I'm not going to
mention this filmmaker's name.
Because I don't know if he
is getting all the calls.
But I feel like I send
people so many times to like
a few people.
And I don't see him
getting those jobs.
And I'm like-- yeah,
it needs to change.
But also like I feel
like I can't change it.
And that is part of
a frustration is--
I'm worried about my own career.
I'm not a teacher anymore.
So you all-- by "you all," I
mean people with the ability
to say you, person, you
should do this movie--
do your own work.
And train your own folks.
And do it for real.
There are such talented people.
And that is why--
and we should talk
about this-- that
is why there is so much
anger and hostility when
a person without experience
gets to do a premium project.
And that is why individual
people, beloved or not aside--
that is why that
frustration happens.
Because we, as makers of
color, are told so long,
I can't take a chance on
that first time filmmaker,
because this is so important.
So when that rule is
not applied to people
who are of European descent--
and I say that
very specifically,
because I'm reading Caste.
And I now know the word
"Caucasian" is made up.
And white is a construct
of colonialism and castism.
So that is why that
is so enraging.
Because yeah, you
can when you want to.
And so what is it going to need
to take for you to want to?
I don't know if it's just like
turning down a bunch of things.
Maybe we should use the
[? Black ?] [? back ?] phone
for that.
Well, a lot of times it's
like you passed the name on,
but it's also
forcing those buyers
because you have power
now to force those buyers,
you work with this filmmaker.
You're going to work
with this filmmaker
and make them work
without [INAUDIBLE]..
I think that's what you're
doing with your company, right,
is saying, OK, I'm
going to be the EP,
but I'm going to
choose the filmmaker.
And so shifting the
dynamics so that you
have to actively dismiss
the person, and in doing so,
dismiss your judgment as
the leader of the project.
So I think that is hopefully
something that we can move to.
But I feel like--
I feel like we need to get a
lot of these buyers in the room
and say--
I'll just speak for myself.
I do not-- I have no
joy of being the only--
not that I'm the only-- but
do you know what I mean?
I have no joy in that,
because that means--
that is not what it should be--
anyway.
Can I talk about my
experience for a second?
Yeah.
I certainly even as a--
I was a sound mixer--
still am-- for many, many years.
But as a personal
disability, I always
came into things
thinking, I've got
to prove that I'm
not incompetent.
Like I live under this fear
that people will look at me
and say gee, I don't know
if that guy can do the job,
simply because I'm
sitting in a wheelchair.
And the experience
with Crip Camp--
Crip Camp was made by
myself and Nicole Newnham--
very experienced, wonderful
documentary filmmaker.
And our collaboration that--
part of the collaboration that
I thought was pretty amazing
was that here was this
able-bodied filmmaker working
with someone who
uses a wheelchair.
And she could see all the
things I wasn't able to access--
simple things like
networking parties
that are way up a flight
of stairs and such.
And it was really our allyship.
But her allyship to me--
that really helped enabled
me as a first time director
to really be a director
and producer with her
on this project.
So I just think that is a
kind of an important thing
to think about.
I wouldn't be-- I wouldn't
be here if it wasn't for her
and how we were able to
craft a collaboration.
She wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for you.
And it totally breaks my
heart to hear you say--
because I think many people
have had those same feelings of,
I'm a fraud, or I'm going to be
thought of as not good enough.
And your reputation is
so stellar that just--
I find that surprising.
So I really value
you saying that.
I remember when Jason
did When I Walk.
Jason DaSilva, yeah.
And there was the New
York Sundance party
for directors in New York City.
And he gets there and it was
up a very narrow, creaky flight
of stairs.
So what was meant to be a
celebration of all of us
who were thrilled to be accepted
by the Sundance Film Festival.
And know somebody
eventually carried him,
but that's not how he
wanted to enter the room.
There was a loss of
control, a little bit
of loss of dignity for him
to have to ask and then
have all of these accommodations
that should have been,
and easily could have
been, worked out before.
Either find another
place or make sure
that he is situated
early enough,
so he doesn't have to
come into the room.
And I could see it.
He was angry.
He was upset.
He couldn't walk-- come into
the room triumphantly the way
that he should have to
celebrate his accomplishment.
So that is--
I think it's
important for people
to hear those experiences
so that hopefully--
and I know it's a burden.
Because it's a burden
for me and for all of you
to constantly inject race
and things sometimes.
You don't want to just
talk about those things.
You want to talk
about everything.
But I do really value you
continually reminding us.
Because a lot of,
I think, behavior
that is offensive or off
putting is not intentional.
And so I think people need to be
reminded of their own blindness
like Roger was
saying with Prudence.
You need-- there was just
a learning curve there.
So like you having us
all describe ourselves--
I love doing it as you can see--
a little bit of the actor in me.
And just the fact
of you asking for us
to do that very simple
thing, hopefully, that
will encourage other people to
think of that when you're not
in the room or on the Zoom.
I think there's a part
of this in which we
are filmmakers and artists,
but we're also activists.
And that it would be
nice to be able to maybe
be more of an
artist certain days
than an activist for my
community and for other people.
Let's talk a little
bit about allies.
So there is-- where does
the responsibility lie?
There's been some calling
out of white filmmakers
who've helicoptered in and
told stories about people
from underrepresented
communities.
The work around that has been
done by the Brown Girls Doc
Mafia and [? ADOC. ?]
And all of these are--
is it our responsibility
to educate?
Is it our responsibility
to actually help
people understand the issues?
Or does some of
that responsibility
lie in the white community?
I'd love to, Lisa,
talk about like that.
Because it seems
like all the work
is being done by
these organizations.
And I don't see that much
coming from the people
who actually hold the
power-- people who
have the white privilege.
I don't see that
coming from them.
I see the work coming
from people of--
people from underrepresented
communities.
And then what you see is proof
positive of the difficulties
that we have.
I'm kind of tired
of doing the work.
I'm tired of being 300%.
And I think probably all of
us and so many of the people
that we prize in our
community feel the same way.
When someone says
they're an ally,
I don't need you to be my ally.
Because that means that you're--
almost infers you're
doing me a favor.
I want you to be someone
who is in lockstep with me
for change, for access, for
opportunity, for extending
beyond the five
Black directors who--
or any kind of directors--
and that you are
seeing your privilege.
You're sitting with
your microaggression.
You are making the
change as a gatekeeper
and realizing that you
have fallen off the wagon.
You haven't done your homework.
You know there is
certainly something
to be said about being
in a pod for COVID.
But I think then we have to
get out of our creative pods.
For those who have the
ability to award projects--
premium projects-- and
to extend themselves
to new people in our community.
Look at Dawn's film--
look at our films
and see who we hire,
if you don't know who to hire.
That's what I would say.
Let's just start there.
We've planted so many seeds
or so many breadcrumbs,
but there is a great amount
of frustration about it
than transfiguring into
actual work and change.
Do people in power
ever see their power?
I mean, is there--
they're just going to--
about these gatekeepers,
the people in power
who make the decisions,
are they really going
to just give up their power?
That's not a question
for me to answer.
[INAUDIBLE] But I
think Lisa brings up
a good point of the difference
really between like allyship
versus solidarity.
I want you to stand
in solidarity with us.
We're all part of
the same community.
You're not doing
something for me
because you're
higher up in a way.
My parents are
Vietnamese war refugees,
so my history of cinema
and my self reflection
is through the Vietnam War.
And that's always the
way I censored myself
in many ways when I
saw myself on screen.
I was a body count.
I was a peasant.
I was just someone who--
shoot off a helicopter.
I never saw myself exist.
And I think people
need to realize
how powerful these
depictions are, especially
for young people.
When they see themselves, when
they see they don't exist,
they see that they have nothing
to strive for or exist in.
I think we have to--
before we can move forward, we
have to like reckon the past.
We have to re-examine
all the dirty truth
of cinematic history,
of America's history.
And before we figure out how
these gatekeepers can "help"
us, quote unquote, they
have to look at their own--
they need to learn from
their own past instead of us
teaching them what they
did to us in many ways.
Yeah.
I wanted to talk briefly
about each of your films.
Dawn, Good Trouble-- obviously
such a towering figure.
What do you feel that
you brought to that film
as a Black woman?
I think a lot.
I'm really like--
I'm writing down
everything you're saying
about, because I'm
going to steal it and
appropriate it and take it
as my own.
But I think-- a few things.
One is Mr. Lewis is always
described as being brave.
And when we talk about
deconstructing racism,
I think one of the first
things I looked to is language.
So what John Lewis and the
other civil rights workers did
is strategy.
It was all strategy-- how they
dressed, where they protested,
what things they targeted,
what their demands were,
how they were all
going to behave.
They coordinated
how they were all
going to behave when
they were arrested.
So focusing on their
intelligence rather than
just their bodies being
put in front of a baton,
that was one big goal.
But I think also--
there was my great grandfather
was a pastor in a Black church.
And so I think that there
can be a misunderstanding
about the role of religion
in the Black community.
It's not just God
and spirituality.
It's real community.
It's a home.
It's a place of safety.
It's where you go for meals
and political meetings.
And so understanding the meaning
of the Black church, I think,
was really crucial
to understanding
why John Lewis and the
other civil rights workers
met in the basement of a church.
A number of the
people were ministers
who were leading them.
There's a tie in-- so
understanding that.
And then the last
thing I would say
is just the level of respect
that you'll give to elders.
Like nobody had to tell me
you don't call representative
Lewis, John.
Like my grandmother would
rise up and strangle me
if I referred to an
elder by a first name.
Even if he said to do
it which he never would.
But just I always came
to him with the respect
that you give to an elder.
And that was taught to me
from the time I could speak.
And I think he knew I understood
our relationship, which
is as much as he was kind
and open and generous,
he was always going
to be my elder.
And I was happy
for him to be that.
And I think that
helped him relax.
That helped him
to want to teach.
And I think a lot of the
interviews-- it's passing on.
It's that oral tradition
of passing things on.
So I think all of
that and that I
think is what part
of what I was saying
is all of that I
didn't have to learn.
I came to the project
with that knowledge.
And so I think I was the
person to tell that story.
But I did also ask
myself the question,
am I the person to do this?
Many people can do many
things about John Lewis,
and I hope that they will.
But I think that
those are the things,
those are the skills,
and also the memories,
and the experiences
that I wanted to lean
into in telling the story.
No, I hear you.
And Jim, let's talk a little bit
about your perspective making
Crip Camp.
For me, I realized after sort of
six months of being in Zimbabwe
with children with very
severe disabilities
that when I was doing
wheelchair races with them,
and they were like fake
faith healing each other.
And I was felt part of that.
And I realized that they were
just like any other kids.
That they were just like--
they just wanted to have fun and
have sex and talk about girls
and do--
and all that broke away.
Talk about Crip Camp and making
that film from your perspective
was revelatory for me.
Well, I mean, I
think that it was
revealing to a lot of people.
We're not looked
upon as people--
rarely we're looked
upon as sexual beings.
But we had this incredible--
Nicole and I had this
incredible 5 and 1/2
hours of this black and
white video footage from 1971
at this camp.
And there's joy there.
And there's humor.
And there's really kind
of deep consideration
that you just really rarely
see this intimate and inside
of a view.
I think that one of the things
that makes our film really
wonderful is that
this is really told
from the inside as
opposed to somebody
really looking down upon us.
And I appreciate that the
people's video theater, that
was there 50 years ago, didn't
go around the camp going, well,
camp director, tell us about
the handicapped people.
But they were right with us,
and they were giving us agency.
And I originally
asked Nicole if she
would direct a film
about the summer camp,
and she said we should--
she wanted me to
direct with her.
And that was-- it
definitely opened up a lot.
Because when I was
asking the questions
to someone within my
community, they trusted me.
They trust me that I would
take what they were telling,
and I would do right
by them and their life.
It was a big responsibility.
Absolutely.
Lisa, you co-directed
with Liz Garbus.
What are the different
perspectives each of you--
you as a Black Latina woman--
Black Latin woman.
Liz-- what did you
talk about that?
It was a really
interesting collaboration.
Ultimately, we were both
passionate and committed
in interrogating this
history of voter suppression
in our country, which
is bedded in racism.
It's embedded in power.
And we had a hive mind
about the structure
and the approach, our
interviews, et cetera.
But we also had a space for
very healthy conversations
that allowed us to speak
from our unique vantage point
and experiences.
And it's in our
personal histories
and how it intersected with
the story that we were telling.
So honor, history,
and interrogation,
and discovery in documentary
films and as does Liz.
And I feel that it helped us to
make a story that is not just
spinach and good
for you, but it has
a lot of deep personal
moments from individuals
who are so important
of making the change
and the progress that has been
made by teaspoons as opposed
to in greater leaps and bounds.
So in our hive mind, we found--
as I like to call it--
we also had a space
for important
conversations defined
by our unique experience
and privileges
in some spaces and lack of
privilege in some spaces.
Bao, you're student
film, Julian,
won an award at Palm Springs.
Talk to me a little
bit about your journey
to Be Water and how
easy or not easy
it was getting to that place of
making that film and getting--
this is an instance
where a buyer actually
went to someone who's Asian
to actually tell the story.
And talk a little bit
about how that happened.
It was a long time coming.
I mean, as everyone
on the panel knows,
it takes a long time
to make a documentary.
I guess for me,
it was five years,
which isn't too long considered
for many other documentary
filmmakers.
But they try to make a
film about the most famous
Asian-American and
not get any traction,
I thought it was
a bit difficult,
just kind of eye
opening in many ways.
It took five years from
the original conception
to when we finally premiered
this year at Sundance.
And I got a lot of pushback
because there had been so
many Bruce Lee documentaries.
There been like 40.
But surprisingly, or maybe
not surprisingly, there
haven't been any
features directed
by an Asian-American about the
most famous Asian-American.
And I knew that the lens that
I wanted to tell Bruce Lee's
story was different.
It was somewhat
personal and honest,
even though I don't know
Bruce Lee personally.
I knew that my perspective was
something that was different.
And that could lend value
to Bruce's narrative.
And ESPN was fortunate--
I was fortunate enough
to connect with ESPN.
And they allowed me
to tell this story
in, again, unapologetically
Asian-American way.
So I think a lot of
people, when they
think of Bruce Lee, he's sort
of this global cultural icon.
He transcends his
race in so many ways
and he's not seen as
an Asian-American.
So I wanted people to know this
was an Asian-American male,
growing up in--
coming to America
in the 1960s, trying
to make it in Hollywood in 1960s
when the Vietnam War is just
starting to boil up.
The Korean war had
ended a decade earlier.
And then two decades earlier
was the World War II where
the Japanese were in turn.
So the enemy of
America was very much
the face of the Asian-American.
And I thought it was
important to put that
into Bruce Lee's narrative.
It's mythology in so many ways.
Because, again, it's hard
enough to be kind of BIPOC
actor/actress today.
But trying to be in
Hollywood in the 1960s
is seemingly impossible.
But people always think
that Bruce Lee just
was always this huge icon
that he never struggled.
So to kind of understand
and unpack that struggle,
I knew it was important
to see all the moments
in American history where
Asian and Asian-Americans were
disenfranchised.
They were ostracized.
They were felt as
humans, as American.
And again, I was really
fortunate to explore
Bruce Lee's life.
And it was a testament
to his character
that he didn't come to
America trying to assimilate.
He came to America
knowing that, I learned
martial arts from Hong Kong.
I'm going to bring that
side of me to America,
and that's how I'm going
to become American.
It's that you're going to
accept the best side of me,
and I'm going to mold that
into what the best of America
can be instead of trying to
assimilate into everyone else's
idea of America
I think that's a
conversation that we're
having today in many ways.
It's like are we
bringing ourselves
by becoming these diverse voices
in a roomful of familiar faces?
Or are we being
ourselves an American
by bringing the best of our
authenticity, our voice,
until what the future
of America will become?
And again, I've learned so much
listening to everyone today.
And we all have to listen more.
We all have to learn more.
And I think that's
something we can take away
in the future for sure.
Absolutely.
Beautifully said.
Well, as we sort of wrap up.
I'd love to just
hear from everyone.
Where do we go from here?
When I look out at
this panel, all of you
are authentically telling your
story from your community,
from your perspective.
And that's a beautiful thing.
But we know that that's not the
case in the industry at large.
So where do we go from here?
Who does the work?
How do we sort of take it
beyond the symbolic diversity
in this corporate
strategy, as Bao
says, of diversity initiatives
to some actual real concrete
change?
I'll just go around, and I will
start with you Lisa Cortés.
Wow, Roger.
Well, listen I-- we want
narratives sovereignty.
We want to that ability
to have unfettered access
to opportunity, to
telling the stories that
are unique from our perspective,
and to receiving distribution
for those stories.
I mean, it's one thing to tell.
It's a whole other conversation
that we haven't had
about the access to the buyers.
So in that, in
this moment, as we
move towards the
sovereignty, I would
ask those who were
former allies but are now
in solidarity with us--
thank you, Bao-- to
step up and to join us.
Because we can expand
the scope of the stories
that are out there
by working together.
Hear, hear.
Jim?
I think that there are
many barriers for people
with disabilities or who
are deaf or hard of hearing
to really have a career.
And one of the things that I've
always thought about is that
if you don't--
can you imagine me working if
you have never seen somebody
like me working?
So we have to kind of
prime the pump here.
We have to look at how
people enter the business.
And if you're judging
someone's commitment or ability
by whether they can
work a 20-hour day
or can carry a tray full
of coffee for people,
you're filtering
out a lot of people
whose experiences and
stories we're missing out on.
And so you have to
look at how you're
judging someone's
worth and someone's
value and their talent.
And it's not that hard
to integrate people
with disabilities into this.
You just have to look
at how other people have
made their career.
And if I'm not able to
work in the mailroom,
doesn't mean that I don't
deserve to be a director
or run a motion picture studio.
And finally, we talk
about inclusion and such.
And what's really
important to me
as somebody with
a mobility issue
is that I want to see
somebody with a disability,
if they won an award to get an
Oscar an Emmy or anything else,
I want us to be entering the
stage exactly the same way
as everybody else does.
None of this waiting in the
wings, or "it's too difficult,"
but that we accept the
fact that if you really
believe in inclusion,
that we also get our time
to enter the stage
not differently
but the same way
everybody else does.
I'm so glad you said that Jim.
Because when we won
the Oscar, Prudence
couldn't come on stage.
Because they said
there was no way
to get her wheelchair onto that
stage at the Kodak Theater.
And it was they were like,
we'll just cut away to her.
And it was devastating.
I mean it was for her.
She didn't have that moment.
Because it wasn't
wheelchair-friendly.
Like, it takes too long,
it was too complicated.
It was too-- it was
just a bunch of excuses
why she couldn't
be on that stage.
And I fought and argued
and fought and they still--
they just wouldn't budge.
Well, I think that it's
important from the red carpet I
see that flight of stairs.
And I'm thinking, why is
there a flight of stairs?
Well, when the
Kodak was designed
or anything else was
done, they didn't really
think about accommodating
people like myself
exactly in the same
league as everybody else.
Or we can do something special,
or we got a lift off there.
True inclusion means
that I get to hold
the hand of my co-director
and co-producer
going up on that stage together
the same way everybody else
does.
Absolutely.
Bao?
Yeah.
I mean I think, again,
having conversations
like these are important.
I think people in power,
people in the industry
can benefit from listening
more and not necessarily
be defensive when we're
having these uncomfortable
conversations.
Because I think
for us, as BIPOC,
as marginalized
filmmakers in some, ways
we've been feeling this level
of discomfort in our daily lives
for so long.
And it's time to-- everyone can
feel a little uncomfortable.
I think immediate
action is knowing,
recognizing that you creating
a diversity initiative,
is it something that's new?
There's been organizations
that have been doing this work
and making space and lanes
for communities for decades.
The Center for Asian American
Media, Third World Newsreel,
now today with Firelight,
with [? ADOC, ?] Visual
Communications, Brown
Girls Doc Mafia--
support these communities.
Listen to these organizations.
And that's something
that's very immediate.
And another thing is
allowing more than one story
to be told about something,
understanding that there's
a danger in the single story.
That there doesn't have to
be one Vietnam War film.
There doesn't have to be
one Asian-American film
about this subject.
There's so many different
ways to tell a story.
And I encourage people to
make as many Bruce Lee films
as possible.
I think sometimes people
think like documentaries are
definitive, historical records.
And no.
They're valuable.
They're very
subjective sometimes.
And I think there's always ways
to learn more from these spaces
And in any--
not just in our industry
and our society,
there's so many ways
that people can help.
Because I think I don't want to
put self-importance onto what
we do as filmmakers.
But I remember watching
your film, Jim,
[? subject Denise ?] saying,
laws won't change attitudes.
And attitudes need to change
through culture, through film,
through books, through the way
we see each other in the world,
through the way we
absorb each other.
And so I think it's important
that in every industry
we work in, we think about
changing those attitudes.
And then laws can change.
And policies can change.
So as an industry, too.
I don't want to think of
this type of conversation
and these initiatives and
this reckoning as a trend
but more as a movement.
Because us existing is an
inevitability in so many ways.
Absolutely.
Dawn, the elder statesman--
stateswoman, sorry--
elder stateswoman,
you bring it on home.
I just thank all of you for
this conversation today.
It gave me a lot to think about.
I want to encourage
particularly-- well,
I would encourage
everyone to remember
that one size does not fit all.
And so people need
different types
of not just support but respect.
So as Jim says, it's not only
people with disabilities.
But people who are not of means
cannot afford to volunteer
and be interns.
And so you can't rely
on a path of plucking
talented interns
who are supported
by wealthy parents
for your talent pool.
So at the stage of who's
entering, making it possible,
or just thinking about
barriers to entry,
just having that thought,
just thinking about that--
but then I think at
our level, I would
encourage people to think about
how you treat each director.
I mean, I have been--
not by everybody--
but most people,
I have really good
relationships.
But on a few occasions I've
been called very aggressive.
I have been called out for
basically loud, Black woman
behavior in situations
where I was, I think,
being a leader of a team.
And so I kind of
challenge people
to think about what assumptions
you bring to your partners,
and understand, I'm
really good at my job.
And if there's something
you're concerned about,
you should tell
it to me straight.
Don't try to hire
a camera around me.
Don't ask for their resume
is of the cinematographers
or producers I bring
to double check
whether they're qualified.
So there are a lot of--
I don't know if I would
call them microaggressions,
but there's cracks around these
seams where you know that as--
my career's great right now.
And I am just thrilled
at the opportunity.
And I'm running after as
many as I can while also
trying to make space.
But when-- it's exhausting
to demand respect
from people at this stage.
And so I just encourage you to
put yourselves in our shoes.
I think empathy is a
great skill builder.
So do what you need
to do to have empathy.
I've been giving a lot of
executives a reading list.
And I've been-- at the top
of that reading list has
been Ibram X. Kendi's How
to Be an Antiracist, which
is the number one book on the
New York Times bestseller list.
Because white people
are reading it.
And they're like oh, OK, I have
to actually be anti-racist.
I can't just sort of
just not be racist.
And I tend-- I give it to
executives, because they're
the ones who are going to
be having to hire people
that don't look like them.
They're the ones who
are going to be--
who are going to empower those
people to commission films.
But I don't want-- and
I'm like the work is not--
I can't do all the work.
You have to-- you
have to do the work.
You have to be an
anti-racist, or the world's
going to leave you behind.
Because we're moving forward.
We're moving forward regardless.
And nothing is going to
stop progress in the world.
It may be slowed down.
It may be temporary
sort of scary moments,
but that's because
progress is happening.
And I think progress
is happening
in the documentary community.
And it's very exciting.
And it's evidenced
by all of you,
and who you are, and
the films you've made,
and what you've done.
All of you just make me so
excited to be in this business.
I'm so proud of each and every
one of your films and all
your work.
And I look forward to seeing
your work for tens of--
to the future--
all the work you're
going to do in the future.
So thank you all for
being part of the Academy,
for the work you're
doing in the Academy
to move it forward, to move
it out of the Dark Ages
into the light.
Thank you.
And then for those
of you who are--
Bao, you will be
an Academy member.
I have no doubt.
Your work is spectacular.
This panel has been great.
And thank you all for
watching Academy Dialogues.
Check out our
previous discussions
and subscribe to the Oscar
channel for more videos.